maligayang pagbabalik sa pag-unawa sa Quantum na impormasyon at komputasyon ang pangalan ko ay John Watus at ako ang technical director para sa edukasyon sa IBM
Quantum ito ang aralin bilang 15 ng serye at ito ang ikatlong aralin ng ikaapat na yunit na tungkol sa Quantum error
correction hanggang ngayon ay nakakita na tayo ng ilang halimbawa ng mga quantum error correcting code kabilang ang nine Cubit Shore
code ang 7 Cubit Steen code at ang 5 Cubit code at napag-usapan na rin natin ang stabilizer formalism na nagbibigay
sa amin ng isang mathematical na pundasyon kung saan maaari nating ilarawan at suriin ang mga ito at marami pang iba pang Quantum error correcting
code ang mga code na nabanggit ko ngayon ay walang alinlangang kawili-wili at kumakatawan sila sa isang natural na lugar upang simulan ang isang
pagsisiyasat ng quantum error correction ang problema ay ang mga ito ay kayang tolerahin lamang ang isang napakababang error rate
ang pagwawasto ng isang error sa isang cubit sa lima pito o siyam ay hindi masama ngunit malamang na kahit gaano karami ang ating suspetsa
kakailanganin nating makayang tolerahin ang maraming mas maraming error kaysa sa iyon upang gawing katotohanan ang large-scale Quantum Computing
sa araling ito ay magtataglay tayo ng unang tingin sa ilang mas sopistikadong Quantum error correcting code construction kabilang ang mga code na kayang
tolerahin ang mas mataas na error rate kaysa sa mga nakita na natin at itinuturing bilang mga promising na kandidato para sa praktikal na Quantum error correction sa
aktwal na mga pisikal na device narito ang isang maikling pangkalahatang-ideya ng aralin magsisimula tayo sa isang klase ng
quantum error correcting code na kilala bilang CSS code na pinangalanan para sa mga mananaliksik na unang natuklasan ang mga ito si Robert Calderbank Peter
Shaw at Andrew Steen ang CSS code construction ay nagpapahintulot sa isa na kumuha ng ilang tiyak na pares ng classical
error correcting code at pagsamahin ang mga ito sa isang Quantum error correcting code bilang bahagi ng talakayan na iyon ay
magtataglay tayo ng medyo mabilis na tingin sa mga classical linear code at pag-uusapan din natin ang ilan sa mga pangunahing katangian ng CSS
code ang ikalawang bahagi ng aralin ay tungkol sa isang code na kilala bilang Torah code na siyang pundamental at talagang
magandang halimbawa ng isang Quantum error correcting code na kayang tolerahin ang isang medyo mataas na error rate sa katunayan ang
Torah code ay hindi isang solong halimbawa ng isang Quantum error correcting code kundi isang walang katapusang pamilya ng mga code isa para sa
bawat positibong integer na nagsisimula sa Dalawa at sa huling bahagi ng aralin ay maigsi naming tatalakayin ang ilang iba
pang pamilya ng quantum code kabilang ang mga surface code na malapit na konektado sa torque code pati na rin ang
mga color code nag-aaral ang mga tao ng classical error correcting code mula pa noong 1940s
at ito ay isang kahanga-hanga at mayamang paksa ang mga linear code ay marahil ang pinakasimpleng uri ng classical error
correcting code at ipapaliwanag ko nang eksakto kung ano ang ibig sabihin ng salitang linear sa kontekstong ito sa loob lamang ng sandali ngunit isang simple
na paraan upang ipahayag kung ano sila ay ang mga ito ay mga stabilizer code na nagkataon na maging classical at malapit nating makita na
ang mga CSS code ay karaniwang mga pares ng classical linear code na pinagsama upang lumikha ng isang Quantum error
correcting code kaya para sa kapakanan ng talakayan na iyon ay kailangan nating maunawaan ang ilang pangunahing mga bagay tungkol sa
mga classical linear code una ay kukuha tayo ng Sigma bilang binary alphabet para sa buong
talakayan na ito at ngayon kapag tinutukoy natin ang isang classical linear code ibig nating sabihin ang isang set C ng mga binary string ng haba n para sa ilang
positibong integer n na nagsasatisfy ng isang pangunahing katangian lamang na kung ang u at v ay mga binary string sa C kung gayon ang string
uxx ORV ay nasa C din dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan ang uxx ORV ay nangangahulugang bitwise exclusive or ng u at v tulad lamang ng
nakita natin nang maraming beses noong aralin lima at anim sa bahagi ng quantum algorithms ng serye at ito ang ibig sabihin para sa isang
classical code na maging linear sa esensya ay iniisip natin ang mga binary string ng haba n bilang n-dimensional na mga vector
kung saan ang mga entry ay lahat zero o isa ngunit sa halip ng ordinaryong vector addition sa mga tunay o complex
numero ay gumagamit tayo ng addition modulo 2 na siyang simpleng exor kaya kung mayroon tayong
dalawang code word u at v ibig sabihin ang u at v ay mga binary string sa C kung gayon ang U plus v modulo 2 o sa ibang salita uux or
V ay dapat ding isang code word sa C at sa pamamagitan ng paraan ang implikasyong ito ay dapat na totoo kahit ang U ay katumbas ng V walang nagpipigil
sa posibilidad na iyon at nagpapahiwatig iyon na ang bawat classical linear code ay dapat naglalaman ng all zero string dahil ang
bitwise exor ng anumang string kasama ang sarili nito ay ang all zero string halimbawa ang three-bit
repetition code ay isang classical linear code sa partikular ay mayroon dalawang posibleng pagpipilian para sa U at dalawang posibleng
pagpipilian para sa V at medyo trivial ang pagpunta sa mga posibleng pares upang makita na palagi tayong nakakakuha ng code word kapag kinuha natin ang bitwise
exor narito ang isa pang halimbawa na tinatawag na 743 Hamming code ito ay isa sa pinakauna sa mga classical error
correcting code na natuklasan at binubuo ito ng 16 binary string ng haba pitong mayroong napaka-simpleng lohika
sa likod ng pagpili ng mga string na ito ngunit hindi ko ipapaliwanag iyon sa video na ito at dapat ko ring banggitin na kung minsan ay makikita mo ang mga string na ito na binaliktad ngunit
para sa ngayon ang pangunahing punto ay kung kukuha tayo ng anumang dalawa sa mga string na ito at exor ang mga ito ay makakakuha tayo ng isa pang string sa
code kaya ito ay isang linear code at ang notasyong 743 sa solong square bracket ay nangangahulugang isang bagay na analogous sa double
square bracket notation na binanggit ko sa nakaraang aralin para sa mga stabilizer code ngunit dito ito ay para sa mga classical linear
code sa partikular ang mga code word ay may pitong bit may 16 na code word kaya maaari tayong mag-encode ng apat na bit gamit ang code at
ito ay nagkataon na maging isang distance three code ibig sabihin ay kailangan mong mag-flip ng hindi bababa sa tatlong bit ng anumang isang code word upang makakuha ng
iba't ibang code word at iyon ay nagpapahiwatig na kayang mag-correct para sa hanggang isang bit flip error ang mga ito ay mga simpleng halimbawa ng
mga code ngunit kahit ang halimbawa ng 74 three Heming code ay mukhang medyo misteryoso kapag simpleng inilista natin ang lahat ng code word kaya kailangan natin ng mas mahusay na mga paraan ng
paglalarawan ng mga classical linear code at mayroong dalawang natural na paraan ng paggawa nito isang paraan ay ang ilarawan ang mga classical
linear code sa pamamagitan ng pagbibigay ng isang minimal na set ng mga code word na nagge-generate ng code ibig sabihin sa pamamagitan ng pagkuha ng lahat ng posibleng
mga subset ng mga code word na ito at xoring ang mga ito magkasama ay makuha natin ang buong code at iyon ay ipinahahayag sa mathematical na mga termino
dito sa screen ang isa pang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol dito ay na iniisip natin ang code na ito bilang isang Subspace ng isang vector space at ang set
ng mga generator na ito ay isang basis para sa Subspace na iyon sa isip na ito ay isang vector space kung saan ang arithmetic ay ginagawa modulo 2 kung mayroon tayong M generator ay
makakakuha tayo ng isang code na may dalawang sa m na elemento ang bawat generator ay nagdodoble ng bilang ng mga elemento sa code at
iyon ay pare-pareho sa katotohanang ang mga classical linear code sa ibabaw ng binary alphabet ay palaging naglalaman ng isang bilang ng mga string na isang kapangyarihan ng
dalawa ang pangalawang natural na paraan upang ilarawan ang isang classical linear code ay sa pamamagitan ng mga parity check lalo na ito ay isang minimal
na listahan ng mga binary string na may parehong haba gaya ng mga string sa code tulad na ang mga string sa code ay nang eksakto ang mga may binary
dotproduct kasama ang bawat isa sa mga parity check string na ito ay zero kung saan ang binary dot product ay simpleng ordinaryo
inner product modulo 2 at muli iyon ay isang bagay na naranasan natin noong aralin lima sa konteksto ng query
algorithms at ang dahilan kung bakit sila tinatawag na parity check string ay na ang isang ibinigay na string U ay may binary product na katumbas ng
zero kasama ang v kung at tanging kung ang mga bit ng U na naaayon sa mga isa sa V ay may even
parity kapag inilarawan natin ang isang classical linear code sa ganitong paraan sa pamamagitan ng isang minimal na listahan ng parity check string ang bawat parity
check string ay hinati ang bilang ng mga string sa Code ng dalawa kaya para sa isang solong code na inilarawan sa dalawang magkaibang paraan ay palagi tayong magkakaroon ng m + Ral
n ang isang mahalagang bagay na dapat mapansin dito ay ang binary dotproduct ay hindi isang inner product sa pormal na kahulugan at sa
partikular kapag ang dalawang string ay may binary dotproduct na katumbas ng zero hindi ibig sabihin nito na sila ay orthogonal sa karaniwang paraan ng pag-iisip natin tungkol sa
orthogonality halimbawa ang binary do product ng string na isa isa kasama ang sarili nito ay zero kaya posible na
ang isa sa mga parity check string na ito ay nasa code mismo kaya iyon lamang ay isang bagay na dapat
isaisip halimbawa tulad ng alam na natin ay ang 3-bit competition code ay isang linear code kaya maaari itong ilarawan sa parehong
paraan sa partikular ay mayroon lamang isang pagpipilian para sa isang generator na gumagana at iyon ay 111 at maaari nating alternatibong ilarawan
ang code gamit ang dalawang parody check string na ito na dapat na pamilyar mula sa ating mga nakaraang talakayan ng
code na ito at para sa 743 hemming code ay maaari nating gamitin ang mga generator na ito at ang mga parody
check na ito at dito sa pamamagitan ng paraan lahat ng ating parody check string ay nagkataon na nasa code mismo
code ang isang panghuling komento tungkol sa mga classical linear code upang ikonekta sila sa stabilizer formalism ang mga parody check
string na ito ay katumbas ng mga stabilizer generator kung saan mayroon lamang tayong Z at identity poly matrix halimbawa ang parity check
string na 11 0 at 011 para sa 3-bit repetition code ay naaayon nang eksakto sa mga stabilizer generator ZZ identity
at identity ZZ at iyon ay pare-pareho sa ating talakayan ng mga observable ng ganitong uri mula sa nakaraang
aralin susunod ay tatalakayin natin ang mga CSS code na siyang mga stabilizer code na maaaring makuha sa pamamagitan ng pagsasama ng ilang tiyak
na mga pares ng classical linear code na may parehong bilang ng mga bit sa kanilang mga encoding hindi ito gumagana para sa anumang dalawang
classical linear code ang dalawang code ay kailangang magkaroon ng isang tiyak na relasyon tulad ng makikita natin ngayon ngunit gayunpaman ang
construction na ito ay nagbubukas ng maraming posibilidad para sa mga Quantum error correcting code batay sa bahagi sa mga bagay na natutunan natin mula sa mahigit 75 taon ng
classical coding Theory nabanggit ko na na sa stabilizer formalism ang mga stabilizer
generator na naglalaman ng Z at identity poly matrix lamang ay katumbas ng mga parity check halimbawa sa three-bit
repetition code ay maaari nating gamitin ang parody check string na 1 1 0 at 011 na nagpapatupad na ang pinakakaliwa dalawang bit ay
pantay at ang pinaka-kanan dalawang bit ay pantay para sa bawat string sa code at ang dalawang parity check string na ito ay naaayon nang eksakto sa mga stabilizer
generator na ZZ identity at identity ZZ para sa 743 Heming code ay maaari nating gamitin ang
mga parody check string na ito at naaayon sila sa mga stabilizer generator na ito kung saan basta pinalitan natin ang bawat isa ng isang z at ang bawat Zero ng identity
maaaring makilala mo ang mga stabilizer generator na ito sa pamamagitan ng paraan dahil ang tatlo sa anim na stabilizer generator para sa 7 Cubit steam code iyon
ay tiyak na hindi nagkataon at malapit na nating makita nang eksakto kung ano ang nangyayari dito bibigyan natin ng pangalang Z
stable ster generator ang mga stabilizer generator tulad nito ibig sabihin sila ay mayroon lamang poly Z at identity tensor
factor kaya ang X at Y ay hindi kailanman lumalabas sa isang z stabilizer generator maaari rin tayong isaalang-alang ang
mga stabilizer generator kung saan lumitaw lamang ang X at identity poly matrix at maaari nating isipin tungkol sa mga stabilizer generator tulad nito bilang ganap na analogous
sa mga Z stabilizer generator maliban na karaniwang naglarawan sila ng mga parity check sa plus minus basis kaysa sa
mga standard basis halimbawa kung babalik tayo sa 743 Heming code ay maaari nating isipin tungkol sa
natitirang tatlong stabilizer generator mula sa 7 Cubit steam code na nagkataon na sumusunod nang eksakto sa parehong pattern gaya ng para sa mga Z stabilizer generator para sa
code na ito ngunit sa pagkakataong ito ay pinalitan natin ang X para sa isa sa halip na Z at ang nakuha natin mula sa tatlong stabilizer generator lamang na ito
ay isang code na kinabibilangan ng 16 na estado na ipinapakita dito na nakuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng mga Hadamard gate sa mga standard
basis state na naaayon sa mga string sa 743 Hamming code at siyempre ang ating code space ay naglalaman din ng
mga linear combination ng mga estado na ito natural na ang mga stabilizer generator ng anyo na ito ay tinatawag na mga X stabilizer generator
kaya walang y o z ang pinahihintulutan sa pagkakataong ito at ngayon ay maaari nating tukuyin ang mga CSS code sa
simpleng mga termino ang mga CSS code ay mga stabilizer code na maaaring ipahayag gamit ang Z lamang
stabilizer generator at X stabilizer generator kaya walang y ang pinahihintulutan at walang x at z na lumalabas sa parehong stabilizer
generator at upang masiguro na malinaw ito ay dapat nating tandaan na mayroong kalayaan sa kung paano natin pipiliin ang mga stabilizer generator para sa mga stabilizer
code at ang sinasabi ng depinisyong ito ay ang isang CSS code ay isa kung saan posible na pumili ng Z at X lamang
stabilizer generator ngunit sa pangkalahatan ay maaari kang pumili ng iba't ibang mga stabilizer generator na maaaring hindi maging Z o X stabilizer generator kung gusto
mo narito ang halos pinakasimpleng non-trivial na halimbawa ng isang CSS code na maaari nating magkaroon kung saan may parehong z stabilizer
generator at isang X stabilizer generator at ang pag-verify nito ay hindi nangangailangan ng higit pa sa isang sulyap dahil alam na natin mula sa
nakaraang aralin na ito ay isang valid na stabilizer code ang code space ay one-dimensional ito ang espasyo na sinalihan ng isang
five Plus Bel at maaari nating masundan na ang ating dalawang stabilizer generator ay kumikilos nang trivially sa vector na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagsasaalang-alang ng
dalawang pagpapahayag ng isang ebit na ipinapakita sa screen kasabay ng interpretasyon ng mga stabilizer generator bilang mga parity check sa 01
at plus minus basis ang 7 Cubit steam code ay isa pang halimbawa ng isang CSS code dahil para sa
pagpipiliang ito ng mga generator mayroon lamang tayong Z at X stabilizer generator at alam na natin muli na ito ay isang valid
stabilizer code at ang N9 Cubit short code ay isa pang halimbawa sa pagkakataong ito mayroon tayong anim na Z
stabilizer generator at dalawa lamang na x stabilizer generator at okay iyon ay hindi kailangang magkaroon ng balanse o
simetriya sa pagitan ng dalawang uri ngunit kritikal naman na mayroon talaga tayong isang valid na stabilizer code at ibig sabihin nito
ay ang bawat isa sa mga Z stabilizer generator ay dapat mag-commute kasama ang bawat isa sa mga X stabilizer generator kaya hindi mo
simpleng mapipili ang dalawang uri ng generator nang nakapag-iisa at sasabihin ko pa nang kaunti pa tungkol dito mamaya sa aralin susunod ay tatalakayin natin ang error
detection at correction para sa mga CSS code at ang mahahanap natin ay ang property na naobserbahan natin para sa 9 Cubit Shore
code na maaari nating i-detect at i-correct ang mga X error at Z error nang nakapag-iisa ay nananatiling totoo sa pangkalahatan para sa mga CSS code
upang maipaliwanag ito nang karagdagan ay isaalang-alang natin ang isang CSS code tulad ng 7 Cubit steam code ngunit maaari itong maging ibang CSS code kung
gusto mo ang pangunahing ideya ay ang mga Z stabilizer generator ay nag-detect ng mga X error
ngunit ganap silang walang malay sa mga Z error dahil ang mga Z stabilizer generator ay palaging nag-commute kasama ang mga Z
error bilang karagdagan ang mga Z stabilizer generator ay nag-commute din kasama anumang Z gate na maaari nating piliing ilapat bilang
mga Correction para sa mga Z error katulad nito ang mga X stabilizer generator ay nag-detect ng mga Z error ngunit sila ay ganap na
walang malay sa mga X error at mga Correction kaya maaari nating sa esensya isipin ang tungkol sa mga Z stabilizer generator bilang kumakatawan sa isang
classical linear code na nagpoprotekta laban sa mga bit flip o sa ibang salita mga x error habang ang mga X stabilizer generator
ay kumakatawan sa isang classical linear code sa plus minus basis na ganap na nakapag-iisang nagpoprotekta laban sa mga flip
sa pagitan ng mga plus at minus State o sa ibang salita mga phase flip error o mga Z error kaya ngayon ay malinaw na kung ano ang nangyayari
sa steam code ito ay simpleng isang 743 hemming code para sa mga bit flip error at isang 743 Hamming code para sa mga phas flip
error muli ang katotohanang ang mga Z stabilizer generator at mga X stabilizer generator ay nag-commute ay kinakailangan
hindi ito magiging isang valid na stabilizer code kung hindi sila at maaari mong sabihin na ito ay magandang kapalaran na ang 743 Heming code
ay gumagana nang ganito ngunit marami pang iba pang mga pagpipilian na maaaring gawin para sa mga pares ng classical linear code na magbibigay sa atin ng valid na stabilizer code
kapag pinagsama sa ganitong paraan ngayon bumalik sa mga CSS code sa pangkalahatan ipagpalagay na ang mga Z stabilizer
generator ay nagpapahintulot ng correction para sa hanggang sabihin nating JX error at ang mga X stabilizer generator ay nagpapahintulot ng correction ng
hanggang k z error kaya sa kaso ng steing code ang J at K ay parehong isa dahil ang
743 hemming code ay kayang mag-correct ng isang bit flip ngunit sa pangkalahatan ang mga bilang na J at K ay maaaring iba
sumusunod pagkatapos sa pamamagitan ng discretization ng mga error na ang CSS code ay kayang mag-correct para sa anumang error sa isang bilang ng cubit hanggang
sa minimum ng J at K iyon ay dahil kapag sinukat natin ang syndrome ang isang arbitrary na error sa ilang
bilang ng mga cubit ay epektibong nagko-collapse nang probabilistiko sa ilang kombinasyon ng mga X error Z error o pareho at pagkatapos ay
ang mga X error at mga Z error ay maaaring ma-detect at ma-correct nang nakapag-iisa kaya basta mayroon tayong dalawang
classical linear code na magkasundo sa kahulugan na nagbibigay sila sa atin ng mga x at z stabilizer generator na nag-commute ang
CSS code na makuha natin sa pamamagitan ng pagsasama ng mga ito ay karaniwang namamana ng mga error correction na katangian ng dalawang code sa kahulugan na katatapos ko lang
ilarawan pansinin na mayroong presyong babayaran bagaman na hindi tayo makakaencode ng kasingyaman ng mga cubit gaya ng magagawa natin ng mga bit
gamit ang dalawang classical code dahil ang kabuuang bilang ng mga stabilizer generator para sa CSS code ay ang kabuuan ng
bilang ng mga parody check para sa dalawang classical code at ang bawat stabilizer generator ay hinahati ang dimensyon ng codee space sa
kalahati halimbawa ang 743 Hamming code ay nagpapahintulot ng encoding ng apat na classical bit dahil mayroon lamang tayong
tatlong parody check para sa code na ito samantalang ang 7 Cubit steam code ay nag-e-encode lamang ng isang cubit dahil mayroon itong anim
stabilizer generator ang huling bagay na ipapaliwanag ko tungkol sa mga CSS code sa pangkalahatan sa araling ito ay tungkol sa mga code space ng mga CSS code
at kung ano ang hitsura nila at magbibigay din ito sa atin ng pagkakataon na suriin nang kaunti pa ang mas detalyadong relasyon na kailangang mangyari sa pagitan ng
dalawang classical linear code upang maging compatible ang mga ito sa kahulugan na maaari nating pagsamahin ang mga ito upang bumuo ng isang CSS
code isaalang-alang ang isang arbitrary na CSS code sa N cubit at hayaan ang Z1 hanggang Zs na maging nbit
parity check string na naaayon sa mga Z stabilizer generator ibig sabihin nito ay ang classical
linear code na inilalarawan ng mga Z stabilizer generator na tatawagin nating CZ upang matulungan tayong matandaan na ito
ay ang code na naaayon sa mga Z stabilizer generator ay kumukuha ng anyo na ipinapakita ngayon dito sa screen sa mga salita ang code ay naglalaman ng bawat
string U na ang binary do product kasama ang bawat isa sa mga parity check string ay zero kung gusto mo ay maaari ka ring
isaalang-alang ang ibang code na nagmula sa parehong mga string na ito na tatawagin nating DZ at ang ideya dito ay iniisip natin ang tungkol sa
mga string na Z1 hanggang Zs hindi bilang mga parity check string kundi bilang mga generator
sa puntong ito ay hindi malinaw kung bakit gusto nating isipin ang tungkol sa code na ito ngunit magagawa natin at magiging relevant ito sa
talakayan na ito ang code na ito ay tinatawag na Dual code ng CZ at karaniwan itong tinutukoy ng CZ per ibig sabihin ang CZ na may perpendicular
symbol bilang isang superscript ngunit tatawagin natin itong DZ at madali itong matandaan dahil ang D ay maikli para sa
dual maaari rin tayong gumawa ng katulad na bagay sa mga X stabilizer generator kaya sa pagkakataong ito ang CX ay ang classical linear code
na ang mga parity check string ay naaayon sa mga X stabilizer generator at ang DX ay ang Dual code ng code na ito bilang isang pag-uusap
ay maaari na nating ilarawan ang mga kondisyon na kailangang mangyari upang ang CZ at CX ay maging compatible sa kahulugan na maaari nating
ipare-pareho ang mga ito bilang isang CSS code sa mga termino ng mga code mismo sa partikular ay dapat na ang
DZ ay nakapaloob sa CX o katumbas nito ang DX ay nakapaloob sa CZ at ngayon ay
posible na ilarawan ang code space ng CSS code na nagmula sa dalawang code na ito at isang paraan upang ilarawan ito ay ang
espasyo ay sinalihan ng lahat ng mga vector na kumukuha ng anyo na ipinapakita sa screen sa mga salita ay mukhang sila bilang uniform
superposition sa ibabaw ng mga string sa Dual code DX ng code na naaayon sa mga X stabilizer generator na inilipat
o exord kasama ang mga string sa code na CZ na naaayon sa mga Z stabilizer generator at mahahanap natin kung ano ang hitsura nito
sa partikular na kaso ng steam code sa loob lamang ng sandali makatuwirang ito dahil ang mga estado sa code space ay dapat na
plus isa eigen vector ng lahat ng mga stabilizer generator at sa partikular ang pagparami ng anumang isa sa mga X
stabilizer generator ay katumbas ng xoring ng kaukulang X string kaya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ang mga uniform superposition
sa ibabaw ng DX na inilipat ng iba't ibang mga string ay lumalabas tulad nito ang iba't ibang mga pagpipilian para sa shift
na kinakatawan ng string Y sa pagpapahayag na ito ay maaaring magbigay sa atin ng parehong vector sa pamamagitan ng paraan kaya ang mga estado na ito ay hindi lahat natatangi ngunit kolektibo ay sinasalihan nila ang
buong code space mayroong simetriya dito sa pagitan ng mga x at z stabilizer generator at
ang mga code na naaayon sa kanila at kaya maaari nating gamitin ang simetriya na iyon upang ilarawan ang mga vector sa code space sa analogous na paraan sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit ng mga x at z ngunit
kailangan din nating palitan ang mga standard basis para sa mga plus minus basis kaya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ang mga hatam operation ay lumalabas sa
pagpapahayag ngayon para sa halimbawang ipinangako na siyang steam code ay makakakuha tayo ng dalawang encoded na ito bilang mga posibleng
encoding ng zero at isa na standard basis State sa partikular ay maaari nating i-encode ang zero State bilang isang uniform
superposition sa ibabaw ng walong string sa Dual code ng 743 Hamming code na lumalabas na kalahati ng mga string sa 743 Hamming code at maaari
nating i-encode ang isa na estado sa katulad na paraan maliban na lahat ng mga string ay exor ng all one string sa kasong ito
dahil ang string na iyon ay nagkataon na nasa 743 hemming code ngunit hindi sa dual nito isang panghuling komento dito ay madalas na hindi natin
masyadong pinapansin kung ano ang hitsura ng mga vector sa ating mga code space dahil sa pangkalahatan ay hindi natin ito kailangan malaman upang magamit ang
mga code kaya kung hindi malinaw ang paliwanag na ito ay hindi talaga iyon isang bagay na dapat ipag-alala ngunit ito ay tiyak na
natural na itanong kung ano ang hitsura ng mga vector sa mga code space ng mga CSS code at ang paglalarawang ito ay nagbibigay ng sagot sa
tanong na iyon susunod ay tatalakayin natin ang isang partikular na CSS code na kilala bilang Torah code na isang halimbawa ng kilala bilang isang
topological quantum error correcting code ang code na ito ay natuklasan ni Alexa Kayv noong
1997 sa katunayan ang Torah code ay hindi isang solong code kundi isang pamilya ng mga code isa para sa bawat positibong integer na
hindi bababa sa dalawa ang mga code na ito ay nagtataglay ng ilang Pangunahing Katangian ang unang pangunahing katangian ay
na lahat ng mga stabilizer generator ay may mababang bigat bilang mga poly operation sa partikular sila ay lahat magiging
bigat apat at ito ay mabuti dahil ibig sabihin nito na ang bawat isa sa mga sukat ng stabilizer generator ay hindi kailangang
magsangkot ng masyadong maraming cubit kung minsan ay nagsasalita ang mga tao tungkol sa quantum ldpc code o Quantum low density parity
check code at ito ang ibig sabihin ng terminong ito kung saan sa kasong ito ang mababa ay nangangahulugang apat kaya ang Tor code ay isang halimbawa ng isang
Quantum ldpc Code ang Tor code ay mayroon din ng tinatawag na geometric locality na ibig sabihin ay hindi lamang
ang mga stabilizer generator ay may mababang bigat ngunit posible rin na ayusin ang mga cubit nang espasyal upang
ang bawat isa sa mga sukat ng stabilizer generator ay nagsasangkot lamang ng mga cubit na malapit sa isa't isa na ginagawang mas madaling ipatupad ang mga sukat na ito sa
prinsipyo at sa wakas ang mga code na ito ay may malaking distansya kaya kayang tolerahin nila ang isang medyo mataas na rate ng
mga Error narito kung paano gumagana ang mga code na ito una hayaan ang capital L na maging isang positibo
integer na hindi bababa sa dalawa at isaalang-alang ang isang L by L lattice na may tinatawag na periodic IC
boundary halimbawa narito ang isang L by L lce para sa Lal 8 at pansinin na ang mga linya
sa kanan at sa ibaba ay mga tuldok na linya at ang ideya dito ay gusto nating isipin ang tuldok na linya sa kanan bilang parehong linya gaya ng
linya sa kaliwa at katulad nito ang tuldok na linya sa ibaba ay parehong linya gaya ng nasa
itaas kaya kung gusto nating talagang mapagtanto ang ganitong uri ng configuration nang pisikal ay kakailanganin natin ng tatlong
dimensyon sa partikular ay maaari tayong bumuo ng isang cylinder sa pamamagitan ng unang pagtutugma ng kaliwa at kanang gilid at pagkatapos ay i-bend ang
cylinder sa paligid upang ang mga bilog sa mga dulo na dating gilid ng itaas at ibaba ng lattice ay magtagpo o
maaari kang tapat na tugmain ang itaas at ibaba muna at pagkatapos ang mga gilid gumagana sa parehong paraan at hindi mahalaga kung paano mo ito gawin para sa kapakanan ng
talakayan ang makuha natin ay isang Taurus o sa ibang salita ay isang donut bagaman ang pag-iisip nito bilang isang inner tube ng gulong ay
marahil ay isang mas magandang larawan na maiisip dahil ito ay hindi malambot ang lattice ay talagang naging lamang ang ibabaw ng isang
Taurus at dito nagmumula ang pangalan na Torah code ang paraan ng paggalaw mo sa
isang Taurus tulad nito na ipinapalagay na makakakilos ka sa pagitan ng mga katabing punto sa lattice ay malamang na pamilyar sa mga taong naglaro ng mga luma
na video game kung saan kung lilipat ka sa itaas na gilid ng screen ay lalabas ka sa ibaba at katulad nito para sa kaliwa at kanang gilid ng
screen at para sa karamihan ito ang paraan ng paglalarawan ko sa lattice na ito bilang kabaliktaran sa pagsasalita nang tiyak tungkol sa isang
Taurus sa isang three-dimensional na espasyo susunod ay iniisip natin na ang mga cubit ay
inilagay sa mga gilid ng lattice tulad ng naka-illustrate dito sa screen kung saan ang mga cubit ay itinutukoy ng mga solidong asul
na bilog pansinin sa pamamagitan ng paraan na ang mga cubit na inilagay sa mga tuldok na linya ay hindi matibay at iyon ay dahil kinatawan na natin ang mga cubit na iyon
alinman ng mga nasa itaas o kaliwang bahagi na isinasaalang-alang na ang mga linya sa itaas at kaliwa ay eksakto parehong mga linya gaya ng mga
itinutukoy ng mga tuldok na linya sa ibaba at kanan at kaya kung mabibilang natin ang lahat ng mga cubit na ito ay makuha natin ang 2 * l^ 2 cubit at isang
paraan upang makita iyon ay mapansin na makuha natin ang l s cubit sa mga pahalang na gilid at L squar cubit sa mga patayo
na gilid kaya iyon ang layout ng ating mga cubit at upang ilarawan ang Torah code mismo kailangan lamang nating ilarawan ang mga stabilizer
generator at mayroong dalawang uri sa kanila una ay mayroon tayong Z stabilizer generator
at ang mga ito ay naaayon sa mga tile o pletes sa figure at pangalawa ay mayroon tayong X stabilizer
generator at ang mga ito ay naaayon sa mga vertex sa figure halimbawa narito ang isa
stabilizer generator ibig sabihin nag-te-tensor tayo ng isa pang poly Z operation para sa bawat isa sa mga cubit na humahawak sa tile na ito kasama ang mga identity matrix
sa lahat ng iba pang cubit at nagbibigay ito sa atin ng isang weight for poly operation at narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang X
stabilizer generator kung saan mayroon tayong mga poly X matrix na kumikilos sa apat na cubit na insidente sa vertex na ito kasama ang
mga identity matrix sa lahat ng iba pang cubit kaya muli ito ay isang weight for poly operation mahalaga na para sa parehong
uri ng mga stabilizer generator ay isinama natin ang mga nagtatapos sa mga periodic boundary at narito ang isang halimbawa ng isang x- stabilizer generator
na gumagawa nito ngayon upang makakuha ng isang valid na stabilizer code kailangan ang mga stabilizer
erator na mag-commute ang mga Z stabilizer generator ay lahat nag-commute sa isa't isa dahil nag-commute ang Z kasama ang sarili nito at nag-commute ang identity
kasama ang lahat ng bagay at katulad nito para sa mga X stabilizer generator malinaw din na ang isang z stabilizer generator at isang x-
stabilizer generator ay nag-commute kapag kumikilos sila nang non-trivially sa mga disjoint set ng cubit tulad ng para sa dalawang generator na ipinapakita
dito ang natitirang posibilidad ay ang isang z stabilizer generator at isang X stabilizer generator ay mag-overlap at
kapag nangyari iyon palagi itong dalawang c kung saan sila nag-o-overlap at kaya nag-commute ang mga stabilizer generator dahil nag-commute ang ZZ
at xx ngayon ito ay hindi isang minimal na set ng mga stabilizer generator sa partikular kung pararami natin
ang lahat ng Z stabilizer generator ay makuha natin ang identity dahil ang bawat Cubit ay nararaming ng z ng dalawang beses
minsan para sa bawat isa sa mga tile na humahawak sa Cubit ibig sabihin nito na ang pagparami ng lahat ng Z stabilizer generator
maliban sa isa sa kanila ay nagbibigay sa atin ng huli kaya sila ay hindi independyente ngunit kung aalisin natin ang alinman sa kanila ay makakakuha tayo ng
isang independyenteng set at pareho rin ito para sa mga X stabilizer generator kaya maaari nating alisin ang isa sa bawat
at hindi mahalaga kung alin ang aming aalisin at nag-iiwan ng l^2 minus isa stabilizer generator ng bawat uri upang
maging malinaw tungkol dito at ito ay isang bagay na binanggit ko sa nakaraang aralin ay talagang nagmamalasakit tayo sa lahat ng mga stabilizer generator na ito at sa mahigpit na
operational na kahulugan ay hindi talaga tayo pipili ng isa sa bawat uri upang balewalain ngunit para sa kapakanan ng pagsusuri ng code maaari
nating isipin na ang isang stabilizer generator ng bawat uri ay naaalis upang makakuha tayo ng isang minimal na generating set na isinasaalang-alang sa
isip na palagi nating mahahalaw ang mga resulta ng mga natanggal na generator na iniisip bilang mga observable mula sa mga resulta ng lahat ng iba pang stabilizer
generator na observable ng parehong uri kaya ang bilang ng mga cubit na naka-encode ng code na ito ay katumbas ng kabuuang bilang ng
mga cubit na 2 * l^2 minus ang kabuuang bilang ng mga stabilizer generator sa isang minimal na generating set na 2 * l^2 -
1 at ibig sabihin nito ay maaari tayong mag-encode ng 2 cubit hindi ko pinagtalunan sa pamamagitan ng paraan na ang code space ay non-trivial ngunit talagang
ito ay non-trivial at iiwan ko sa iyo na hikayatin ang iyong sarili na walang paraan ng pagparami ng mga stabilizer generator sa isang paraan na nagbibigay sa atin ng
negatibo -1 na beses ng identity kaya iyon ang Torah code mismo at sa puntong ito ay maaaring hindi pa
malinaw kung bakit ang code na ito ay dapat maging mabuti para sa Quantum error correction nananatili para sa atin na suriin ito at ang mahahanap natin ay ito ay sa
katunayan ay isang kahanga-hangang Quantum error correcting code upang maunawaan kung paano gumagana ang Torah code bilang isang Quantum error correcting
code ay magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pagsasaalang-alang ng iba't ibang mga error at ang mga syndrome na nabubuo nila ang unang bagay na dapat pansinin ay ang
Tor code ay isang CSS code dahil lahat ng aming stabilizer generator ay Z o X stabilizer
generator at ang ibig sabihin nito ay ang mga X error at mga Z error ay maaaring ma-detect at marahil ay ma-correct
nang nakapag-iisa at sa katunayan ay mayroong simpleng simetriya sa pagitan ng mga Z at X stabilizer generator na nagpapahintulot sa atin na suriin ang mga X
error at mga Z error sa mahalagang parehong paraan kaya tutukan ko sa mga X error na marahil ay natatuklas ng mga Z
stabilizer generator at maaari mong i-translate ang lahat sa mga Z error na marahil ay natutuklas ng mga X stabilizer generator gamit ang eksakto parehong
mga ideya narito ang isang figure na naglalarawan ng ating dalawang Square cubit sa mga gilid ng isang L
by lattice na may mga periodic boundary at maaari nating isipin na ito ay nakalatag sa ibabaw ng isang
Taurus sa sandali lahat ng cubit ay asul na nagpapahiwatig na ang mga ito ay mga cubit na hindi naapektuhan ng
mga error kaya dapat mong isipin na sa puntong ito ang estado ng mga cubit na ito ay nasa code space para sa
code na ito tulad ng binanggit ko ang aming pokus ay magiging sa mga X error at sa loob lamang ng sandali ay gagamitin natin ang mga magentang bilog upang ipahiwatig ang mga cubit na
naapektuhan ng mga X error ang mga X error ay natutuklas ng mga Z stabilizer generator na naaayon
sa mga tile sa figure kaya ang magagawa natin ay ang hayaan ang mga Puting Tile na magpahiwatig ng mga plus isa na resulta ng sukat o sa ibang salita
mga entry sa syndrome na naaayon sa generator na iyon habang ang mga gray na tile ay magpapahiwatig ng minus isa na resulta ng
sukat maaari mong isipin ang isang plus isa na resulta o sa ibang salita ang isang puting tile bilang nagpapahiwatig na ang kaukulang
stabilizer generator ay masaya lahat ay tila okay para sa generator na ito samantala ang isang minus isa na resulta o isang gray na tile
ay nagpapahiwatig na ang kaukulang stabilizer generator ay hindi masaya dahil halata na ang isang error ay nangyari upang maging sanhi nito
resulta kaya sa sandali lahat ng aming stabilizer generator ay masaya dahil walang nangyaring mga error ngayon kung iniisip natin
ang tungkol sa isang z stabilizer generator lahat ng ginagawa nito ay sinusukat ang parity ng 4 cubit na humahawak sa tile kasama
ang kaugnayan sa standard basis kaya ang isang plus isa na resulta ay hindi nagpapahiwatig na walang X error ang nangyari sa apat na
cubit na ito kundi nagpapahiwatig ito na ang isang even na bilang ng X error ang nangyari samantalang ang isang minus isa na resulta ay nagpapahiwatig
na ang isang odd na bilang ng X error ang nangyari kaya ngayon ay ipakilala natin ang isang X error at tingnan kung ano ang
nangyayari ang dalawang Z stabilizer generator na naaayon sa mga tile na humahawak sa Cubit na ito ay hindi na masaya dahil ang
x error na ito ay anti-c commutes kasama ang parehong generator na ito o katumbas nito sa mga termino ng standard basis ay nasa atin na
isang estado kung saan ang parehong mga set ng apat na cubit na naaayon sa dalawang tile ay may odd parity kaya iyon ang epekto ng isang solong
X error kaya kung susukatin natin ang syndrome na ito at alam natin o ipinapalagay natin na isang X error lamang ang nangyari ay madali nating
mahihinuha kung aling Cubit ang na-flip at maaari nating i-flip ito pabalik gamit ang isang xgate ngayon tingnan natin kung ano ang nangyayari
kapag nagdadagdag tayo ng karagdagang mga X error at sa partikular tingnan natin kung ano ang nangyayari kapag ang pangalawang X error ay naganap sa isa pang
Cubit na humahawak sa isa sa mga gray na tile sabihin nating ang gray na tile sa itaas tulad ng
nito ang tile na iyon ay masaya na ngayon dahil dalawang x error ang nangyari sa mga cubit na humahawak sa tile na ito at ang dalawa ay even kaya
ang dalawang x error na ito ay magkasamang nag-commute kasama ang stabilizer generator para sa tile na ito ang isa pang paraan ng pagsabi nito ay ang
pangalawang X error na ito ay inilipat ang lahat ng standard Bas na estado para sa apat na cubit mula sa odd parity pabalik sa even
parity ang tile sa kaliwa ng bagong X error na ito sa kabilang banda ay hindi na masaya
maaari nating ipagpatuloy ang prosesong ito ng pagdaragdag ng mga bagong X error at basta bumubuo tayo ng isang chain ng mga katabing X error kung saan ang katabing ibig sabihin ang mga cubit ay humahawak sa
parehong tile ay epektibo nating itutulak ang minus1 na resulta ng sukat sa paligid at ang mahahanap natin ay palagi tayong may
minus isa na syndrome measurement na resulta sa mga endpoint ng mga chain ng mga katabing error kaya palagi nating matutuklas ang mga chain ng
mga katabing X error basta mayroon silang mga endpoint maaaring mayroon sa pamamagitan ng paraan ng maraming chain ngunit babalikan natin
ang posibilidad na iyon mamaya posible naman na magkaroon tayo ng isang chain ng mga katabing X error na
walang n point na ibig sabihin ang ating chain ng mga Error ay maaaring bumuo ng isang closed loop kaya magdagdag tayo ng higit pang mga error upang
bumuo sila ng isang closed loop tulad nito halimbawa mayroon na tayong even na bilang ng X
error sa bawat tile kaya lahat ng stabilizer generator ay masaya na at ang natuklasan natin ay ang mga closed
Loop ng mga katabing X error ay hindi natutuklas ng code na ito dahil nakuha natin ang all plus1 syndrome sa ganoon
kaso kaya maaaring mukhang medyo nakakadismaya iyon sa katunayan kailangan lamang natin ng apat na katabing X error upang bumuo ng isang closed loop
at umaasa tayo ng mas mahusay kaysa sa isang distance 4 code gayunpaman ang ilang closed Loop ng
mga katabing X error ay nasa stabilizer mismo alalahanin na mayroon tayong X stabilizer generator para sa bawat vertex sa
lettuce at kung pararami natin ang mga katabing X stabilizer generator ay maaari tayong bumuo ng mga closed Loop ng X
operation tulad ng mayroon tayo ngayon dito para sa closed loop na binuo natin kaunti lamang kanina kaya ang ilang closed Loop ng X error
tulad ng ipinapakita ngayon dito ay hindi talaga mga error sa lahat dahil sila ay nasa stabilizer kaya wala silang ginagawa sa code space mayroong gayunpaman ang ilang
closed Loop ng X error na hindi nasa stabilizer at samakatuwid ay kumakatawan sila sa mga non-trivial na error na hindi
natutuklas ng code at mayroong medyo simpleng paraan upang maipakilala ang iba't ibang uri ng
loop ang mga loop na tumatawid sa bawat linya sa lattice ibig sabihin ang bawat patayo na linya mula itaas hanggang ibaba at bawat pahalang na linya
mula kaliwa hanggang kanan ng even na bilang ng mga beses ay palaging mga produkto ng mga X stabilizer generator na kinabibilangan ng halimbawa
na ipinapakita sa screen pati na rin ang mga Loop na maaaring mas kumplikado kabilang ang posibilidad na tumatawid sila sa mga periodic boundary ngunit
gayunpaman sa pamamagitan ng pagparami ng mga closed Loop ng x Error sa pamamagitan ng mga X stabilizer generator ay maaari silang epektibong mabawasan pababa sa
wala at tiyak na totoo sa pamamagitan ng paraan na makakakuha lamang tayo ng mga loop tulad nito sa pamamagitan ng pagparami ng mga X stabilizer generator dahil ang bawat X stabilizer
generator ay naglalagay ng even na bilang ng X operation sa bawat pahalang na linya at sa bawat patayo
na linya ang iba pang uri ng closed loop na maaari nating magkaroon ay isa na tumatawid sa hindi bababa sa isang linya ng odd na bilang ng mga beses tulad ng
ang ipinapakita ngayon dito na tumatawid sa bawat pahalang na linya nang isang beses lamang at narito ang isa pang halimbawa na tumatawid sa
bawat patayo na linya nang isang beses lamang kaya ang mga ito ay mga halimbawa ng mga non-trivial na error na hindi natutuklas ng code ngunit ang susi
dito ay ang tanging paraan upang bumuo ng closed loop tulad nito ay ang pumunta sa paligid ng Taurus alinman sa paligid ng butas sa
gitna ng Taurus o sa pamamagitan ng butas o maaaring parehong ito ay isang topological na katangian
tungkol sa aurus ito ay lahat tungkol sa mga butas karaniwang at iyon ang dahilan kung bakit ito ay tinatawag na isang topological Quantum error Cor
code sa mga termino ng visualization na ito ng isang two-dimensional lattice na may mga periodic boundary ang isang chain sa kategoryang ito ay kailangang
pumaikot sa isa o parehong mga periodic boundary sa isang paraan na ginagawang imposible ang pag-contract ng Loop na iyon sa isang
punto sa pamamagitan ng pagparami nito ng mga X stabilizer generator ang isang chain tulad nito ay maaaring mas
kumplikado kaysa sa ipinapakita ngayon dito ngunit ito ang pinakamaikli na maaari posibleng maging ganoon na loop dahil kailangan nitong kahit paano pumaikot sa
isa o parehong mga periodic bound ary at ang implikasyon nito ay ang pinakamababang bigat ng isang non-trivial
na hindi natutuklas na error ay ang L anumang closed loop na may mas kaunting error kaysa sa iyon ay dapat mahulog sa unang kategorya at samakatuwid ay
nasa stabilizer at ang mga chain ng mga error na hindi bumubuo ng mga closed Loop ay natutuklas ng code at iyon na iyon iyon ang dahilan kung bakit gumagana ang code na ito
at ang makuha natin sa huli ay isang 2 l^2 2 L stabilizer code ginagamit natin ang 2 L S
cubit upang mag-code ng 2 cubit at ang code ay may distansyang L susunod ay sasabihin ko nang kaunti tungkol sa
pagwawasto ng mga error sa Torah code bagaman hindi ko masyadong papasok sa mga detalye kung sinukat natin ang syndrome at
makakita tayo ng ibang bagay kaysa sa all plus1 syndrome kung saan nagsasalita ako dito tungkol lamang sa mga Z stabilizer generator
kung gayon ang mga minus isa na resulta ay nagpapahiwatig sa atin ng mga endpoint ng isa o higit pang mga chain ng mga katabing X error at maaari tayong subukang mag-correct
ng mga Error na ito sa pamamagitan ng pagpapare-pareha ng mga minus isa na resulta at pagbuo ng isang chain ng mga X Correction sa pagitan ng mga ito at habang
ginagawa namin ito ay makatuwirang pumili ng pinakamaikling daan para sa aming mga Correction halimbawa kung sinukat natin ang isang
syndrome tulad ng ipinapakita ngayon dito ay maaari nating piliin ang daan na ito sa pagitan ng mga unhappy na tile at ilapat ang X
Gate bilang mga Correction sa daan na ito siyempre ang aktwal na chain ng mga Error na nagdulot ng syndrome ay maaaring
naiiba tulad ng ipinapakita ngayon dito ngunit okay iyon basta ang mga error at ang mga correction ay magkasamang
mahuhulog sa stabilizer maaari ring mangyari na ang aming mga Correction ay bumubuo ng isang loop sa paligid ng
Taurus na masamang ito dahil sa paggawa nito ay nagdulot tayo ng isang logical error kaya ang estratehiyang ito ng pagwawasto
sa mga pinakamaikling daan ay nagwawasto ng mga mababang bigat na error ngunit maaaring hindi ito gumana para sa mga mas mataas na bigat na error ngunit siyempre ay hindi natin maaasahan
ang higit pa mula sa anumang Quantum error cting code mas malamang marahil depende sa noise model ay ang
aming obserbasyon ng isang grupo ng mga minus isa sa syndrome at sa kasong ito ay maaari nating gumamit ng mahusay na mga classical algorithm upang tulungan
kaming ipare-pareha ang mga ito at makahanap ng pinakamababang bigat na error na kumakatawan sa syndrome tulad ng binanggit ko sa nakaraang
aralin ito ay maaaring hindi palaging nagwawasto ng pinaka-malamang na paliwanag para sa syndrome ngunit ito ay gumagana nang medyo mahusay sa pangkalahatan
at palaging nagtagumpay sa pagwawasto ng mga error na may bigat nang mahigpit na mas mababa sa kalahati ng distansyang L at dapat ko ring
banggitin na mayroong iba pang mga estratehiya na mas angkop para sa iba't ibang error model mahigit na 25 taon na mula nang
matuklasan ang Tor code at sa oras na iyon ay nagkaroon ng napakaraming trabaho sa Quantum error correcting code kabilang ang
iba pang mga topological Quantum error correcting code na inspirado ng Torah code pati na rin ang mga code batay sa iba't ibang
mga ideya tiyak na hindi ko maibibigay sa iyo ang isang komprehensibong listahan ng lahat ng iba't ibang code construction na kilala ngunit kakamot ako sa ibabaw
nang kaunti at maigsi na banggitin ang ilang kilalang halimbawa una tulad ng natuklasan lumalabas na hindi talaga
mahalaga na ang Tor code ay may mga periodic boundary ibig sabihin posible na putulin lamang ang isang bahagi ng Tor code at
ilatag ito nang patag sa isang two-dimensional na ibabaw sa halip na sa isang Taurus at ang makuha natin sa paggawa nito ay tinatawag na isang surface
code halimbawa kung puputulin natin ang mga gilid ng isang lattice sa pattern na ipinapakita ngayon dito na may tinatawag na rough edge sa
itaas at ibaba at smooth edge sa mga gilid at naaayon doon ay isinama natin ang mga kaso ng gilid para sa mga stabilizer generator
pagkatapos ay makakakuha tayo ng isang code na maaaring mag-encode ng isa lamang na Cub sa pagkakataong ito ngunit ang code ay gayunpaman ay namamana ng pinaka-
mahalagang katangian ng Tor code sa partikular ang mga non-trivial na hindi natutuklas na error para sa code na ito ay dapat
naaayon sa mga chain ng mga error na alinman ay umaabot mula sa kaliwang Gilid hanggang sa kanang gilid o mula sa itaas hanggang sa ibaba
depende sa kung ang mga ito ay mga chain ng X error o Z error ayon sa pagkakasunud-sunod posible rin na putulin
ang mga gilid nang pahilis upang makakuha ng kung minsan ay tinatawag na mga rotated service code at ang paggawa nito ay maaaring makatulong para sa paggawa ng
mga code na mas ekonomikal sa mga tuntunin ng kung gaano karaming cubit ang ginagamit halimbawa kung kukuha tayo ng surface code na ito
at itapon ang ilan sa mga cubit na nag-iiwan ng isang parisukat na nakatuon nang pahilis ay makuha natin ang isa pang service
code basta tinukoy natin ang mga stabilizer generator sa boundary sa tamang paraan ang mga diagram tulad nito ay
nakatutulong upang malinaw kung paano tinukoy ang mga stabilizer generator kung saan ang mga itim na tile kabilang ang mga bilugan sa mga gilid ay nagpapahiwatig ng X stabilizer
generator at ang mga puting tile ay nagpapahiwatig ng mga Z stabilizer generator ang mga nasa boundary sa pamamagitan ng paraan ay dalawang Cubit XX o
ZZ stabilizer generator lamang sa pagkakataong ito at karaniwan mong makikita ang mga diagram na ito na pinaikot ng
45° ang isa pang kawili-wiling klase ng mga code na nahuhulog din sa pangkalahatang kategorya ng mga topological code ay mga color
code hindi ko ipapaliwanag nang eksakto kung paano sila gumagana ngunit isang paraan ng pag-iisip tungkol sa kanila ay ang mga ito ay mga geometric generalization
ng 7 Cubit steam code kaya isaalang-alang natin ang pitong cubit team code at ipagpalagay na binibilangan natin ang ating mga
cubit gamit ang KCET ordering Convention tulad ng ipinapakita ngayon dito sa screen maaari nating iugnay ang pitong
cubit na ito sa mga vertex ng graph na ipinapakita ngayon dito at ang mahahanap natin ay ang mga stabilizer generator ay naaayon
sa mga tile o mukha na nabuo ng mga gilid ng graph at para sa bawat tile palagi tayong may z stabilizer
generator at isang X stabilizer generator na kumikilos nang non-trivially sa eksakto ang mga cubit na matatagpuan sa mga vertex ng tile na
iyon maganda ito dahil tulad ng para sa Torah code mayroon tayong geometric locality para sa code na ito kaya hindi natin kailangan
na ilipat ang mga cubit sa mahabang distansya upang sukatin ang mga stabilizer generator at ang katotohanang ang mga Z at X stabilizer generator ay palaging kumikilos nang non-trivially sa
eksakto parehong mga set ng cubit ay maganda rin para sa mga dahilan na konektado sa fault tolerant Quantum computation na
sasabihin ko pa nang karagdagan sa susunod na aralin ang mga color code ay mga quantum error correcting code na nagge-generalize nito
pangunahing pattern kung saan karaniwang ginagawa natin ang parehong bagay maliban sa iba't ibang mga graph halimbawa narito ang isang graph na may
19 vertex na gumagana ito ay nagbibigay sa atin ng isang code na nag-e-encode ng 1 Cubit sa 19 at nagkataon na magkaroon ng
distansyang lima ang mga ito ay tinatawag na mga color code sa pamamagitan ng paraan dahil ang isa sa mga kinakailangang kondisyon sa graph ay ang mga mukha ay maaaring tatlong-kulay ibig sabihin
ang maaari nating kulayan ang mga mukha ng tatlong kulay at hindi tayo kailanman nagkakaroon ng dalawang mukha ng parehong kulay na nagbabahagi ng isang gilid ang
mga kulay ay hindi talaga mahalaga para sa code mismo mayroon lamang tayong x at z stabilizer generator para sa bawat mukha anuman ang kulay nito ngunit ang mga kulay
ay lumalabas na mahalaga para sa pagsusuri kung paano ito gumagana kaya iyon ang dalawang kilala
pamilya ng mga code ngunit marami pang iba pang mga construction na kilala kabilang ang mga batay sa mga ideya na katulad ng mga code family na ito pati na rin
ang ganap na iba't ibang mga isa ang isang partikular na halimbawa ng isang Quantum error correcting code na kamakailan lamang
natuklasan ng ilan sa aking mga katrabaho sa IBM ay kilala bilang gross code na pinangalanan kaya dahil ang isang gross ay isang dosenang
dosin o 144 sa partikular ang code na ito ay nag-e-encode ng 12 cubit sa 144 cubit at mayroon itong
distansyang 12 hindi ko ipapaliwanag kung paano gumagana ang code na ito nang detalyado ito ay katulad ng Tor code maliban na ang bawat isa sa
mga stabilizer generator ay nagsasangkot na ngayon ng dalawang karagdagang cubit na kaunti lang ang mas malayo wala itong planer embedding
tulad ng isang surface code ngunit mayroon itong tinatawag na Baner impeding ibig sabihin dalawang layer ng cubit ang kailangan sa halip
ng isa nahuhulog ito sa isang pamilya ng mga code na tinatawag na byari bicycle code at ang partikular na kapansin-pansing bagay tungkol sa kanila ay
ang mga ito ay mas mahusay kaysa sa Torah code o isang surface code sa kahulugan na marami pang cubit ang maaaring ma-encode habang sabay-sabay ay
nagtitiis ng halos parehong rate ng mga Error para sa gross code kailangan ng karagdagang 144 cubit para sa syndrome
measure kaya ang kabuuang bilang ng mga cubit na kinakailangan ay 288 na ginagawa itong isang napaka-promising na kandidato para sa teknolohiya ngayon
at tinatatapos nito ang araling ito na tungkol sa mga construction ng quantum error creating code kabilang ang mga CSS code ang Torah code at isang
sulyap sa iba pang mga Quantum Code construction kabilang ang mga surface code at mga color code umaasa akong sasali ka sa akin para sa
susunod at huling aralin ng serye tungkol sa fault tolerant Quantum computation na tinutugunan ang hamon ng Pagsasagawa ng
comp na mga komputasyon sa naka-encode na Quantum State gamit ang mga operasyon at Computing component na sila mismo ay madaling kapitan ng
mga error paalam hanggang sa muli